all right last one for today and you can
see it's a multi-part question so it's a
bit of a doozy
uh and there's going to be a lot of
notation here to follow so i'll do this
to try and make it clear
um but what's going to emerge from all
of this is one of the really cool
um sort of i guess corollaries things
you can do with mod arg form that you
didn't necessarily expect
that you could do we'll get to that at
the end you can sort of anticipate it
just by the way the question
is written but uh we'll get to it in due
time so let's start from the top
it says express this complex number in
real imaginary form so in cartesian form
now you can see you've got this complex
number divided by this complex number
so another way of what they're saying is
can you you know
realize the denominator and get this
into a distinct a
and a distinct b that you've got
separated out rather than two complex
numbers being divided one by the other
so let's have a go with that this is
part a so
it's got written as this 1 plus i root 3
on 1 plus i so to realize the
denominator i'm clearly going to have to
multiply by the conjugate
of the denominator so that's one
takeaway i on
one take away i what are we going to get
well on the top i can start to expand
this thing out
so you're going to get if i if i
distribute
let's distribute this guy to the one and
also
to the minus i and then i'll do the same
with the second term you're clearly
going to get 1 minus
i there's the first term plus i
root 3 this is me distributing the
second
set of terms so there and there
this is going to be minus
i squared root 3. i think i've got that
right
and double check my working and then all
of that is going to be multiplied by
1 plus i 1 minus i right so this is
going to be a
classic whoopsie daisy a squared
take away b squared situation here
let's start to collect some like terms
and tidy this thing up so
you can see here let's highlight these
are going to be my real terms here
even though this has i's in it it's got
two of them i squared so that's going to
become
plus 1 right there take away negative 1.
so i'm going to get 1 plus root 3.
that's just going to hang out the front
there's the first part of the real
component
and then let's see here if i factorize
out that i there
so i'll do oopsy does i might as well
just stay in orange that's fine
factorize out the eye what's that going
to leave me with well you can see
there's a negative 1 here and a plus
root 3 here so that's going to be
negative 1 plus root 3.
and therefore on the denominator i've
got
1 squared plus 1 squared in the end so
that's just going to be 2.
by the way quick note before we go any
further into this question i just want
to explain a bit now that we've got sort
of
mod arg form and multiplication of
complex numbers
in that form a little more into our
heads think about what's going on here
right
why is it that we multiply by the
conjugate to
realize the denominator well if you
think about what a complex number
and its conjugate look like visually
let's draw a really
quick and dirty set of complex planes
over here
1 plus i what is that well it's going to
be 1 1 there it is let's call that 1
plus i
and then its conjugate 1 minus i will be
here
here
one minus i so here's one number and
here's the other
now what happens when you multiply these
two numbers together well
two things happen whenever you multiply
by a complex number first one
is your scaling that comes from the real
component and the second thing
is that you rotate which comes from the
imaginary component right
now when they scale you know this one is
root 2 this one is root 2 and so that's
why when you scale them together you get
2 root 2 times root 2. but and this is
the really cool bit right what happens
when you deal with the rotation
well because conjugates are in opposite
directions right
so here is the uh argument for this guy
and here's the argument for this guy
because one of them is going to be in
this case this is
plus pion4 and this is minus pi on four
the rotation of pi and four in one
direction and the rotation of power four
in the other direction
one clockwise and one anti-clockwise
they are going to
cancel out and so if you cancel out one
rotation and that rotation
you end up just in the middle now where
is the middle and the answer is the
middle is on the real
axis right so that's why this complex
number multiplied by this complex number
is the exact right rotation so that you
end up back on
the real axis it's sort of like rotating
one way and then rotating back
yeah so that's why realizing the
denominator has this
effect all right uh let's uh let's
finish
by i should say multiplying by the
conjugate has this effect of realizing
i think a nice way to sort of tie this
up in a bow is just to clarify
what is the real component what is the
imaginary component
and you can see here this big fraction
this is
1 sort of plus root 3 divided by 2 and
then it's separate to this guy
being divided by two so i think we
should write it like so
one plus root three on two there's your
real component
plus and then here comes the the
imaginary component negative one
plus root three on two and then that i
is hanging out at the end
there's part a there it is in real and
imaginary form
okay in seemingly unrelated news let's
move into part b
part b says write each of these numbers
separately this is talking about the
numerator and the denominator
and denominator and numerator in what
arg form they want to convert into polar
and hence express this in mod arg form
okay so
what i'm going to do for you is going to
be yeah
slightly long but we're going to work it
out together we will be able to in the
future
prove some of the results that will make
the working our matrix a lot faster
but we haven't proven them yet so let's
just do it in long form okay
let's get each number in mod arg form
i've already started with
1 plus i so 1 plus i as you can see even
from this quick dirty diagram over here
it's going to have a modulus of root 2
and then its argument is going to be as
i was discussing before pi and 4
right so therefore i can say this is
going to be
cos pi on 4 plus i
sine pi over 4.
okay so that wasn't too hard what about
the other one well
1 plus i root 3 think about this right
this is going to exist in another right
angle triangle like so
where you've got this is the real
component this is the imaginary
component
so i need to know i need to know this
length the hypotenuse to work out the
modulus
and then i need to know this angle here
to work out the
argument and hopefully both your
pythagoras and trig are good enough that
you will be able to recognize
my modulus here is going to be 2 and
then my argument here is going to be pi
on 3.
okay so there are the two numbers so
then how do i express
this division here in mod arc form i
want it as one single number
well it's going to be this guy divided
by this guy which means
this is the numerator this is the
denominator so what does that end up
with well
i'm going to say this equals in fact i'm
just going to
be slightly lazy i'm going to duplicate
this guy
and i'm going to duplicate this guy
and i'm just dividing one by the other
like so
okay so this is this is
let's see here 1 plus i root 3 divided
by 1 plus i but it's not in mod arg form
yet i've got the two complex numbers
sort of separate
so how do i combine them well this is
going to require some knowledge of trig
here and it's going to get messier
before it gets neater so stay with me
okay let's do the easy part first 2
divided by root two there's moduli
easy to deal with um you know two of
course is root two times root two
so a root two will cancel which gives
you just root two
on the top that's nice what do i get
when i am
trying to deal with this guy and this
guy and combine them into one well
even though it's going to look in the
short term very very messy and
i'm actually going to go down here i'm
going to need the whole length of the
line
i'm going to basically do what i did
before right which is you've got to
multiply
by by conjugates in order to realize the
denominator it's just that
my conjugates are going to look somewhat
messier now because mod arg form
tends to be much longer to write so
let's go and get stuck into it right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
multiply by the conjugate of this
denominator here so instead of
cos pi and 4 plus i sine pi and 4 i'm
going to multiply by cos pi and 4
minus i sine pi on 4. so let's have a go
at that you can see this part is going
to stay the same so i'll just duplicate
this down
but let's multiply through and this is
what you're getting
normally and now the conjugate looks
like oops i'm using the wrong tool
know what you're doing there we go
that's going to be
if i can keep the right bits that's
going to be the conjugate right there
there's the minus instead of the plus so
we'll duplicate that
all right now you're looking at this and
you're thinking oh my gosh this is going
to look gross
it is going to look gross for the time
being but stick with it because a
beautifully
elegant result emerges let's let's start
it out
to begin with i'm just going to begin
expanding things because there's no
sense there's no reason to put it off
right i've got this root 2
hanging out the front and then what
happens when i multiply this
mess together well let's have a go at
just
distributing terms through right so i'm
going to have
cos pi on 3 and it's going to multiply
by
each of these terms here and here right
so i'm going to get cos
pi on 3 cos pi on 4 and then i'm going
to get
minus we'll put that i out the front and
i still have cos pi of 3 that's being
distributed
this time as 2 sine pi on 4.
so far so good so what i've done is i've
multiplied this first by cosine four and
then
second by i sine pi on four so that's
what i've got here
all right next term to distribute it's
going to be this i sine pi
on three so i go i sine pi on 3
first i multiplied by cos pi and 4 like
i did earlier
and then watch out because you've got a
minus and another factor of i here so
it'll be minus i
squared sine pi on 3
sine pi on 4. my goodness that looks
disgusting but that's okay
it's going to come good in a second
before we return to this numerator
let's deal with the denominator so what
i've got here
like i always do with trying to
rationalize or realize denominators i'm
getting difference of squares here
between here
and here right so clearly the point of
this was to get an a squared minus b
squared situation on the denominator
which in this context is cos
squared pi on 4 there's my a squared
and then minus here comes b squared it's
i
squared sine squared pi on 4.
okay so it's i sine pi on 4 which you've
got from here the whole thing's been
squared so there's the i squared
there's the sine squared i'm good to go
all right now
i've been putting off dealing with this
numerator it's time to address it as
i've done before i'm going to use colors
to help clarify what's happening here
you can see
as always with the complex number
there's the real parts and then there's
the imaginary parts and i want to deal
with them quite separately
so here is the first real component i
see there are no eyes
this part on the end here is also going
to be real because that i squared
is going to factorize out to be just
negative 1
right in the same way you're going to
have this guy in here that has an eye in
it clearly so it's imaginary
and same deal here that's got an item so
i'm gonna have to deal with that
so let's deal with them and sort of put
them beside each other and separate out
i've got this whoopsie daisy i've got
this root 2 hanging out the front
and then let's write all the real
components first so i've got cos
pi on 3 cos pi and 4
and then i've got be careful this is the
minus times -1 so that's what i get with
a plus
sign of pi on 3 sine of pi 4
take a breath that's all the real
components now we do the imaginary
components
so i'm going to have plus i and i notice
you know this one's negative and this
one's positive so i'm going to write
this one
first just for convenience for a
factorized out the i so that leaves me
with
sine pi on 3 cos pi on 4
minus cos pi on 3 sine
pi on 4. so you can see i'm writing this
in terms of the angles so pi 3 always
comes first
pi and 4 always comes second all right
what am i going to get down
on the denominator well we really need
our exact values to be on hand very
quickly
so cos of pi on 4 is 1 on root two so
we're squaring that cos squared so one
over two
times one over two last i checked that
was a half
here you're getting minus i squared we
saw that up above here so that just
becomes
plus and then nicely for us sine pi 4
is also 1 and root 2. so 1 under 2 times
1 over 2 is a half
so i'm adding a half how convenient this
whole denominator here is just going to
be 1. so from this line on
i don't need to worry about it okay now
this still looks like a mess what can i
deal with this right how how can i deal
with this i should say
well if you have a look at this term
here
or this pair of terms i should say even
though it looks so awful i wonder if it
rings any bells from your trigonometry
earlier
this year i forgive you if it didn't
because it's been a while but
hopefully it's sort of like ringing your
head like this cause cosine sign where
do i recognize this from
and if you need a bit of a memory prompt
if you go back to your reference sheet
if you go all the way to page 2 under
trigonometry
you might see this compound angle
business
going on down here right so you can see
cos of a plus b
looks a whole lot like what i've got
here do you see that it's that same uh
cos cos sine sine but over here instead
of having cos cos
plus sine sine i've got cos cos minus
sine sine so what you can see on the
reference sheet there what's being
quoted for you is the sum
of angles the sum of you know a plus b
but here i don't have
um you know the the minus sign that's in
the reference sheet i've got a plus so
it's actually the opposite case
this is not cos a plus b this is cause a
minus b so what i can write is and stay
with the same
color the colors of a minus b i'm going
to get in this context
is pi on 3 minus pi on 4.
and then i've got a plus and now that
you've seen the connection with the
compound angle for cos you might also
recognize
that this this tangled mess here is
going to give you the compound angle for
sine it's the same deal though right see
how sine a plus b it's got a plus sign
in between sine a cos b plus cos a sine
b well the fact that i've got a minus
sign here means it's my opposite it's
not sine a plus b it's sine a
minus b which is a relief because i can
get rid of this now
in mod arg form i'm supposed to have the
same thing
the same theta on the cos theta plus i
sine theta um those angles are meant to
be the same
so it's a relief for me that i'm getting
pi on 3 minus pi on 4
in the front and in the back as well and
so at last
we finally got there i can actually
simplify this out and write it in
um mod arg form now that i have
everything in my you know here comes my
r
this is my cos theta plus i sine theta
now maybe you don't know you're a third
minus a quarter off the top of your head
but
the question itself gives you a clue
because you can see where they're headed
is pi on 12. and of course pi on 3 is
4 pi on 12 and pi on 4 is 3 pi and 12 so
when you subtract them you're getting
1 pi on 12 minus i sine
pi on 12.
that was a lot there's a lot of
trigonometry um this result in here by
the way that
took us all of this expansion all this
kind of thing basically these three
awful looking lines in here
we are going to take that as a proven
result a little bit later in the course
that's part of why we use mod arc form
we don't have to go through all of this
every single time we can just show
there is a subtraction of angles and a
division
of these moduli here now
how can i conclude this how does this
get me cos pi and 12
insert form this is really interesting
right because cos pi on 12 is not
something that we have in exact
values at least it's not something we
ask you to memorize we ask you to
memorize like
0 pi on 6 pi on 3 pi on 4 i skipped that
one
pi on 2 and multiples thereof
but pi on 12 is not one of them however
we can see
that it's it's in here right so how do i
get
this in terms of s well
thankfully i want to remember like where
do i get this from this whole complex
number to begin with
well where i got it from was from this
division right this division was in fact
1 plus i root 3 on 1 plus i so
i can actually say based on part a which
i seem like i did a lifetime ago right
here is the same thing this is
1 plus i root 3 divided by 1 plus i and
down the bottom what i just got out of
my mod arc form is also
1 plus root 3 and 1 plus i the same
thing right so in other words
i'm taking this one object and i'm
looking at it from two different angles
so i can therefore say this is part c
part c this guy here i first did it
in rectangular form it's identical to
this
i just did it in mod arg form so we're
going to pull out a trick that we did
from last week which is to compare
the parts on the left and the right hand
side that are useful to me which in this
case
is going to be i think this is the color
i used this is the real component on
the right hand side and this is the real
component
on the left so i say compare real
parts that gives me i'll put the
cosplayer 12 on the left hand side
because that's where i want it
root t cos of pi on 12
equals 1 plus root 3 on
2 so now just to get cos pi 12 by
itself cos pi on 12 i'm just going to
divide both sides by root 2. so that
gives me
this and now you can see why we don't
make you memorize
the exact value for an angle like cos pi
and 12 because gross one plus root three
on two root two
i don't wanna have to commit that to
memory but isn't it amazing that
actually going into complex numbers
which sounded like it was very exotic
and weird and strange
actually gives us insight to parts of
mathematics namely trigonometry that
we've been dealing with for years
but we couldn't answer before if you
take cos plan 12 put it into your
calculator
it's going to give you some weird
garbled number in fact it's not going to
give you just any read
regardless number it's going to give you
there's a previous calculation i was
doing let's see it's going to give me
cos
of pi on 12. there it is 0.9659 etc
and i can confirm that i got the right
side by putting in 1
plus root 3 and then i'm going to put 2
root 2
on the bottom and that looks pretty good
to me